[Applaudissements]
parce que je sais que c'est moi qui
produit l'émission donc c'est moi qui
offre les taxis merci d'avoir pris le
taxi à deux ça m'a fait quelques
économies merci
[Applaudissements]
merci
comment ça se passe
tu seras défrayé tu me donneras ton
ticket
[Rires]
[Musique]
alors c'est un chirurgien il est sur le
bloc il s'apprête à intervenir auprès de
son patient et donc il lui dit ça va
aller Philippe ça va aller arrête de
paniquer ok tu prends une grande
respiration et tout va bien se passer et
le patient il lui dit je suis désolé
docteur de vous dire ça mais moi c'est
pas Philippe c'est c'est Patrick il lui
dit oui je sais c'est moi Philippe
mon amour
[Applaudissements]
ça va faire du bien cette émission mon
chéri
Jean-Marie c'est son mari
non mais ça va
ah là ça va ça va tout va bien tout est
sous contrôle
arrêtez arrêtez
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je crois je pense que ma femme est
devenue sourde ah bah l'autre tu dis
attends je vais te donner un tuyau pour
être sûr et pour savoir la vérité tu
sais ce que tu fais quand tu rentres ce
soir
à peine ta franchi la porte tu dis à
haute voix chérie qu'est-ce qu'on mange
toi si elle te répond pas tu progresses
dans la maison tu vas dans la pièce où
se trouve ta femme carrément la cuisine
par exemple tu rentres dans la cuisine
et là tu redis à haute voix chérie casse
qu'on mange toi si elle répond toujours
pas
tu viens derrière elle 50 cm derrière
elle tu mets tes mains comme ça
qu'est-ce qu'on mange et si elle répond
pas c'est qu'elle est chaude vous le mec
qui dit d'accord il rentre franchit la
porte qu'est-ce qu'on mange rien voilà
la cuisine et ce moment il va derrière
sa femme qu'est-ce qu'on mange et là sa
femme elle se retourne et elle lui dit
pour la troisième fois des lasagnes
[Applaudissements]
ça fait 45 ans qui sont mariés ils
veulent fêter leur 45e année de mariage
il invite au restaurant il lui dit
écoute ma chérie maintenant ça fait 45
ans dis-moi les vérités est-ce que tu
m'as déjà trompé
sa femme elle le regarde et d'écoute je
te rappelle la maison qu'on a acheté et
dit oui fallait un crédit oui bon le
crédit il a été refusé et il se met
après il a été accepté
voilà j'ai couché avec le banquier le
regarde il dit c'était la seule fois il
dit non
je te rappelle tu t'es fait virer de ton
travail et tu dis oui
il t'a rembauché ton patron et dis oui
bah parce que j'ai vu le patron et puis
bon il dit bon c'est pas grave tu as
couché pour la bonne cause il dit c'est
tout et dit non rappelle
pendant les élections il fallait 150
voix
[Applaudissements]
aller à l'école ça on a compris
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quelle date pourquoi et ben parce que
ils sont méchants avec moi ce mac de Moi
Moche dessus et me jette des pierres
Jean-Pierre tu es le proviseur de ce
lycée
[Applaudissements]